the FBI director will be in the
spotlight today when he testifies before
the Senate Judiciary Committee James
Comey is expected to be asked about the
FBI investigation into the Trump
campaigns possible Russian ties Tommy's
testimony comes as Congress prepares for
a potentially explosive hearing next
week with former acting Attorney General
Sally Yates she's previously sounding
the alarm about after national security
adviser Michael Flynn Jeff Piquet's is
uncapitalized investigation just under
ten months old but there is another key
figure in this investigation who will
testify next Monday and as mentioned
that is former acting Attorney General
Sally Yates who believed that former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
was compromised when he worked in the
White House in January and early
February Flynn was fired after
misleading the vice president about his
contacts with Russian ambassador Sergei
Kiss lyac members of Congress will want
to know why the White House waited more
than two weeks to fire Flynn Yates was
originally supposed to testify in March
but that hearing was abruptly canceled
by then committee chairman Devin Nunez
just yesterday members of the Senate
Intelligence Committee boarded buses to
CIA headquarters in Langley Virginia
where they were briefed on sensitive
information related to the investigation
into Russian interference but today on
Capitol Hill the focus will be on
director Comey who as you know has
developed a reputation for surprises the
last time he testified in an open
hearing here on Capitol Hill he sent
shockwaves Nora alright Jeff thank you
so much